on doit tuer des policiers et puis il
faut donner des aussi des coups de PO
aux gens qui passent le but du jeu
devenir le caïd l'ennemi public numéro 1
la violence est ici beaucoup plus
supposée que visuelle mais le jeu choque
les syndicats de policiers choc en
priorité c'est le scénario proposé parce
qu'on sait que la violence existe
est la tente dans l'environnement de
l'enfant là le scénario est particulier
et il fait appel à tout ce qu'il y a de
plus mauvais chez chez l'homme et chez
l'enfant en général du côté de
l'importateur en affirme s'être posé
beaucoup de questions avant de mettre ce
jeu sur le marché un avertissement en
anglais puis un autocollant
déconseillant la vente au moins de 16
ans on se défend d'avoir voulu un
scénario uniquement basé sur la violence
et l'immoralité dans la vie de l'école
qui a connu quand dans dans les petites
classes il avait autant de fois envie
d'être le gendarme que d'être le voleur
le syndicat policier a saisi le
ministère de l'Intérieur l'importateur
du jeu se dit lui prêt à rendre son
avertissement déconseillé au moins de 16
ans plus visible